and then there are people that want to
be like hey you know I talked about in
my act feel you're like hey yeah my set
up for soccer it's like oh my [ __ ]
god
oh really yeah yeah I know dude they
should make a movie about that yeah but
see that's you being not a part of I
dude I know I know I know I'm the same
[ __ ] way yeah I know it means it like
to you know I do it but but it's funny
that I try though to participate in
those conversations like if I'm at a
meeting right so let's say I see you at
a meeting hey what's up Bobby Hey Dude
what's how was your weekend it's pretty
good how was yours what'd you do okay
yeah I went with my kids to the mall
what about you though I keep asking
flesh right there yeah I think I don't
know what so I go is it good it explains
a lot like in conversation or when he's
around my family
he leads the entire conversation or else
because he doesn't want to have to
listen to anybody else
oh I do that makes sense now
yeah I want to do that yeah which is I
can't bring it up but I think I feel
like I feel like I feel like that's what
honestly that's what Donald Trump is I
feel like he got in office because he
was doing basically buy and people
legitimately thought it was refreshing
and voted for him because people are
like you can't say that he's like I said
it yeah yeah and he's also a guy that
like has seen everything right when he
has it Russia in a hotel room missing on
[ __ ] billion dollars he has and the
kinds of people he's met you know I mean
like guys like Don King or like his
[ __ ] right
tell people what to do him what to do
yeah look at my shoes right Duncan yes
sir
you're amazing go get the cheese you
know but he's seen and done every single
thing he has all the money in the world
I mean you go to like even the Trump
Soho in New York yeah right and you walk
in there and you're
like wow this place is nice there's a
library yeah you know me and Sebastian
had coffee at that library once cuz for
funsies you know yeah and we were like
looking around gorgeous he's got a
thousand of those yeah all over the
world yeah this dude like he's just
completely jaded and I think that's what
it is he just says whatever he wants to
say I do whatever I want to do and
that's that mm-hmm well I want to know
what you had what you and when did you
have his coffee was Sebastian in the
Trump I was well you had coffee with
Sebastian Maniscalco yeah another
fantastic commedia in New York so this
is whatever I'm not even kidding okay so
I'm there I can't imagine the two of you
why I can't imagine having coffee with
you at having coffee with Sebastian at
the edges well your passion and I in an
oddly enough like we've were friends
like yeah I want to his wedding and
stuff so I'm yeah okay it's a no it's a
weird thing but like you know but so
what I was doing I was smoking a
cigarette at the Trump Soho because I
was shooting a movie okay and I was
there for a week it was my first day and
I and I was smoking a cigarette and I
see Sebastian walk out of the hotel so
you didn't know he was there no no you
were there right so he walks by me I go
said Seb
I said sab like 20 times right he
doesn't turn around because he's
probably used to fans when was this
this is way before so not that right and
he got in a cab and he just drove off no
yeah so I was angry well but he didn't
know it was I know I know maybe I didn't
say it louder
so at Exxon dude you just walked by me
right because those you know yeah and
then he was doing a corporate event and
then that night he came back and then he
called me wet coffee
hmm that suffice to you [ __ ] say
that whole [ __ ] story [ __ ] look
for that never blame wet well by the way
you started that off by saying you're
not gonna believe this
I believe that
yeah yeah yeah well do you believe it
yeah
[Music]